all right let's move on to the next
award though which is the saltiest
moment I hope I'm not on here there's
probably a lot of them all right all
right uh first one is pro ZD after
hearing Connor skips cut scenes and gone
watches anime two times so I was I was
salty with him when I heard this I feel
like that has a very good shot of
winning it was a very iconic moment I
feel for the trash taste yeah it was
just the sheer disgust it's it's when
like someone who's not familiar with
trash day is just kind of like gets a
shocking Revelation about what the type
of [__] that we talk about you know it's
like you almost forgot what the name of
our show was yes uh God I'm still salty
I'm still salty about this one the thing
that makes this that makes me so salty
about this one is that you know if if I
was prepared for like you know second
place if I was prepared for like second
place not being you know having to go to
the manga Cafe then I would be like okay
whatever it was it was in the agreement
you know yeah but the [__] Joe he had
to drag me down with him yeah because
like we actually we did have enough room
for one more person in the five-star
hotel yeah yeah and we were like God if
you want to and then Joe was like no you
should you should stay in the morning I
think you were also kind of a little bit
intrigued to see what it's like yeah but
also you came to regret it so yeah yeah
yeah it was uh not a good night's sleep
that I got oh sure that her first hotel
it was so overpriced yeah for what it
was that was from the Japan road trip I
still have I still hear the sounds of
just the dude fapping
I just I just I can't I can never unlive
that now
uh then we got Connor losing to gun in
the extreme gamer quiz [__] that wasn't
right that was uh no one expected that
one yeah yeah that was one of the
biggest surprises of the year I did not
expected the one time where Connor could
have gone in Easy always a big surprise
when it's me losing wow you know what I
mean like I'm tired of this [__] when I
win it's not a big surprise you know
this is [__] up you know I got on when
you beat me on the anime quiz you know
then then you could say yeah yeah
exactly okay uh and then the boys after
hearing Emily's noodle
[Music]
actually that that is probably the
saltiest mermaid yeah yeah I think that
was the saltiest moment out of
everything this year and then uh Ludwig
not being the biggest YouTuber from
school this is close though he's very
close I think he actually might have
overtaken him oh really maybe uh I mean
he's you know that's the only reason
he's continued YouTube
contractual obligations yeah yeah he's
out of the game after that but yeah they
can only be one winner what do you guys
think it'll be Sydney I want I want I
mean
I want Pro ZD to win because like also
Sydney was the saltiest you know all
right let's find out the saltiest moment
of this year's trash taste is
Pro ZD
it was well this is a good song I'm
right there I feel like this was one of
the most discussed moments in a lot of
like our guest episodes
it was the pain he exuded it was like he
paused he was like yeah he didn't even
like say anything just just the sign of
disappointment that's all that was
needed to be said I think it started off
like that but like the more the podcast
went on and the more he heard us talk
the more you could see that anger just
boiling up and boiling up you're a voice
actor
I remember Tim turning to Joe and being
like what are you gonna say whatever
what's what's next Joey what are you
gonna say now
wow holy [__]
which was 16.4 what how is that wasn't
even closed oh yeah lots of people
it makes sense well deserved
congratulations on being the saltiest uh
moment of the Year congratulations sorry
someone I still sometimes watch anime
two times speed that's all right song
when I'm on your side
disgusting all right let's move on to
the next one which is the most monkey
moment I think it's only fitting that I
present this one of course yeah
why don't you read out the nomination
let's see what we have Connor flooding
three hotel rooms because of TFT
everyone had a banana okay I mean that
just is a monkey that is literally a
monkey moment what else do we have uh oh
my God okay
um Sydney getting tricked about a Tim
Tom slam
that was my face do you want to explain
what a Tim Tam slime is I want to fix
this so a team 10 I'm saying what a team
10 slam is supposed to be is when you
buy him as an Australian biscuit yes
it's a chocolate biscuit and uh a Tim
Tam slam is when you bite off two ends
of the biscuit and you use it as a straw
to suck up your tea or coffee or
whatever beverage you're having milk
sometimes uh but we myself and the
entire smash audience tricked Sydney
into thinking that a Tim Tam slam was
when you take a packet of tim tams and
you slam it on the ground and then you
open the packet and eat the crumbs she
believed that [__] so much so to the
point where she tried to do it at the
signing that we I had to stop her as the
as as being a good husband everybody
everyone who was there was just like God
how dare you and that's when that was
the exact moment when I realized that
gaslighting foreigners is an Australian
Pastime I don't know how that started
Australians like I was like what's
what's Australian culture people are
just like oh you know it's the wildlife
or the [__] beer no like a true
Australian would just try to Gaslight a
foreigner uh that's the one thing I
found in common with everyone that I've
met in Australia oh yeah absolutely I
fixed my mind uh Connor Segway fall on
the road trip yes well I mean Conor is
one but also gone yeah yeah I think I
broke mine literally wrote something
there
um this this one is I I this this one
you know the worst part was with that
pad thai wasn't even that good like it
was a pretty bad it wasn't even that
good I thought how could you [__] this
up this is uh simultaneously the like
one of my most monkey moments listening
to and one of my saltiest moments
listening to as well that that was I I
could not I could not believe my soul
left my [__] body because how much is
a pad thai usually it's like three
dollars like two like three dollars is
still like expensive it's like you can
get some for like one dollar one dollar
fifty
um
they paid 20 bucks
I knew we were getting scams but we were
already sat down and I was like okay I'm
like getting scammed in Pad Thai is like
paying seven dollars for Pad Thai all
right
I mean they're all honestly pretty
monkey uh four of these include Connor
yes which is hilarious four isn't it
you're in this one as well
so either way I'm taking it yeah yeah
Sydney which I have a feeling is not
going to win because uh I mean I I I
think the TFT thing I think it must be
the thing I remember the play-by-play
yeah of getting the message from Connor
because me and Connor were gonna meet up
at the bar and he's like oh I'm gonna be
late I need and he takes me again oh I'm
gonna be really late and then it was
just like the progression over there I
flooded my room I flooded three rooms
I'm not dead I flooded people think I
flooded my room because I was taking a
bath I was actually just playing TFT it
was just like the evolution of this
story
hey I got Diamond though so I'm still
Diamond to this day all right let's find
out who wins then the winner is
Connor flooding three hotels
I bet it wasn't even close what was it
57 7
that's [__] all second place uh
let's look at the next one then next one
is the new one wildest guest episode yes
we did have a lot of guest episodes this
year a lot of them had a lot of wild
moments a lot of crazy moments a lot of
crazy stories uh and we feel like it
would be only be fair to have some kind
of representation of like all the guests
and all the guest moments that uh
happened this year which is why the
nominations that uh you nominated were
Now red Nigel of course yes we got Pete
Peta yes uh we got the moist man himself
Charlie we got uh Hassan we got Michael
Reeves and we got Pro ZD and we got
shindoel Ludwig and of course Felix a
lot of episodes
a lot of episodes and that's only like
the tip of the iceberg or the uh actual
guest episode yeah this year and a lot
of them yeah they did have some wild
moments yeah they definitely had some
wild moments I mean Nigel uh that entire
[__] episode I have simultaneously
wiped from my memory but I remember like
the emotions I felt during that episode
I presumed because he was like a science
YouTuber he'd be more reserved yeah he
was so wrong yeah he was off the charts
he's a mad scientist uh Hassan I'm just
happy that we had an anime basically an
anime only episode and it was actually
one of like our most in-depth anime only
episodes we've had uh in the history of
this podcast I think
and then obviously Michael Reeves is
just [__] insane all the time yeah he
brought it to trash days as well uh Pete
just is like the most amazing
Storyteller no one tells stories no one
tells a story like that and no one has
stories like Pete uh and then of course
Charlie is you know just he finally got
to defend his uh JoJo take to us live in
person
yeah this is why talking your feelings
out yeah don't be angry people online
just just get them in the same room and
just have a conversation yeah we
honestly got to see some of his
Contraptions as well oh yeah very very
interesting and then obviously someone
who is never coming back on this podcast
because definitely hates at least yeah
I'm surprised he agreed to do a claw
obviously shindo making us all open our
third eyes with just the most wild
interpretations of hentai yes uh Ludwig
just because he's Ludwig and uh Fearless
because he's Felix yeah yeah I mean the
Felix episode the one of the things that
stood out to me was uh he somehow agreed
with at least one of each of our [__]
takes he he started like he started
neutralizing yeah yeah yeah yeah he
started World War Three and then became
allies with everyone at the same time I
don't know how he managed to do that uh
but that was pretty impressive yeah who
do you think's gonna win though
um I think it might be between Pete Now
red I think it might be between either I
think those were fan favorites but I
think long-term viewers of trash taste
because you know a lot of the guest
episodes get a lot of viewers from
outside communities yeah yeah but I did
notice that the the trash taste
Community loved those shows yeah
definitely I would say I mean I I
enjoyed recording all of these all these
questions all of these episodes were
like really really fun to enjoy
absolutely to record sorry
um but yeah in terms of like wildest I
would say that now red and Pete had the
craziest stories because they they went
on some side quests in their lives it's
just a man that said yes to everything
for 30 years to 40 Years of his life
yeah it's like all right now I have
enough stories forever yeah for a
lifetime yeah and really and Gnar red
was just like let's just try something
crazy yeah I don't have I don't have
like a danger function a number in my
brain we're lucky that now red decided
to be a YouTuber yeah I'm not an evil
scientist I mean we did like Tales of a
dangerous scientist who's grown up doing
dangerous experiments but they can only
be one winner unfortunately and the
winner of the wildest guest episode is
it's no Reds well done congrats Nigel
thank you for not blowing up the earth I
hope you have remembered where you found
that uranium from because I I keep you
happy for another day please don't be
angry yes yes oh yeah I'm sure you know
if we find someone with a meth kind of
like if we find a meth lab in this place
I wouldn't be surprised you know but
whatever just for a YouTube video just
for a YouTube video that's fine yeah
it's a tax write-off